>>Hello YouTube. I'm going to answer a question
about whether we're going to get growth. And
let me tell you the real problem. The problem
is that the growth we were having was not
real. It was like an uninsured risk-taking
that gave the illusion of growth with huge
amount of downside risks that we're paying
for now. Let me give you an example: take
two companies, one company makes two dollars
a share, doesn't have insurance, eventually
it's going to go bust. It looks good on paper.
Another company makes a dollar a share, but
it's very robust. It does not have downside
risk, it's insured against what I call a
black swan. The first company looks better
according to economic trick metrics, according
to economic measurements, but the second one
in the long run is the one that will survive.
So let's not shoot for growth. Let's shoot
for robustness. Let's work on a society that
is robust to model error, robust to the black
swan. A society different from the one the
banks gave us. Let's snatch it back away from
them. Thank you.